security
loving someone
because I it goes back to what if he was
a bomb
remember if I'm like no job look at men
no job look at men love us with no jobs
men love us I don't know why they take
all night security work blessing
sorry I don't want to do you like that
they'll genuinely love us no job you
could just be not oh I'm so happy to see
you
but they are they have but they have to
work still so like they're still
providing the lifestyle right so hell no
I'm not gonna no it's just that's what
this is what Kevin Samuels would say
that's what the men do when they make up
a lot of money they know they gotta
marry a bum they got someone that don't
it like I said a lower paying job but
not just kidding I'm just kidding but
not no job because no job is like why
not what about McDonald's
like the manager like the region manager
I was trying to make it better stop
trying to make it better Brittany
what
yeah flipping burgers
don't worry he got a raise from 12 to 15
and up I'm gonna need my honey bunch to
try harder I can't he's gotta aim higher
than me but he's jacked he's in the gym
I see what you're trying to do and I
just cannot no look at it look it so so
that's your option that's option one you
love him he's the smooth talker you know
the type they make us all fall in love
absolutely then you forget their bums so
so so because they had to have the time
to learn how to talk absolutely guys
with jobs
for this right so you you really love
him he knows how to talk make you feel
nice whatever but he flips burgers for
12 an hour however this is a really you
could also hypothetical you could also
that's why it's fun you could also
to visualize it he's also jacked his
stuff now the the old guy let's say
so you're 30. let's make him 57.
I like to be exact 57.
with the beer belly you're not really
attracted to him but but
you're not even worried about child
support this man's so rich you're not
even worried you don't even you are
chilling in the you got the car the see
and you had both and you left for some
cheating respectfully but now these are
your options and learning the wall has
come
you're Walling
I am Walling right now
um that neither one sounds appealing no
you gotta pick one oh my God so I don't
understand you'd rather die alone than
do that I'd rather I understand but now
okay there's a gun to your head you have
to pick the man
and man number two works a lot he's
driven he's so driven you know
but I'm not that attracted to him no
it's a little simpy
I like a little Stimpy okay uh she's
smiling she's thinking about security
she's thinking about it she's thinking
about it
so which one really loves me though
they both really love you oh [ __ ] yeah
you gotta pick one
oh I feel like a part of me is like
shallow in once
once the guy like I I wanna I don't know
I feel like it's where I'm a little
shallow with looks the hot guy
the phone we call that the guy at the
foam Cannon party what does that mean oh
Cal explained so we shout out shout out
roller tomasi
um so so the guy at the foam Cannon
party is like the guy that women sleep
with right away but he's like they don't
look at us long term so they sleep with
him quicker where the guy they feel like
they could lock down like makes him they
make me jump through hoops right because
like the the first one they have like
the animal more like genuine desire for
yeah and they're like oh she said you
don't have a job
yeah I I feel like that's that's my God
to honest truth like I would rather date
the trainer or date the guy in
McDonald's
that loves me because I just I can't
that's basically like a sugar daddy and
if I if I wanted a sugar daddy I would
got one years ago
like I don't want one now just because
the options are changed no because it
still is like I mean I don't know I get
it because he has money it's not
technically aiming low but it's like
[Music]
I don't know I feel like both could use
work one like let's get you a different
job and then even the older guy let's
get you in the gym this is what the men
want us to know this isn't Bill demand
this isn't build a bum
you can't build men yeah yeah that's why
I feel like a lot of us women if you
know we we don't wanna
if we have to if we don't want the bun
we don't want the beer belly we're gonna
die alone oh I got a question can you
turn a hoe into a housewife
if the hoe and I put that in your
clothes on purpose oh
if the hoe wants to be a wife it has to
be her she has to want that in her heart
because you can't make someone be
something they don't want to be so yeah
like I I no like I feel like you'd have
to want that I don't think a guy can
make you beat up
I mean
you still have to would be even if he
was like willing to maybe show you the
ropes and teach you you'd still have to
you'd have to be the first person that
wants that and I think there was a
couple that you had used last night
um
I can't remember the couple but you had
said I think you're talking about okay
yeah yeah you're talking about them I
don't really think she cares about being
someone's wife
no so if she doesn't care about being
someone's wife
then she's not gonna be away so you
can't change that so that's why my
answer is you can't make somebody they
don't you cannot make them be what they
do not want to be that's what my dad
always would tell me like he would
always say I always say to let Pete like
the biggest mistakes people make is
trying to control people and make them
into something they're not and like
people are who they are yeah and that's
what you know that's what I said you
were the least delusional one on that
planet
I think sometimes your idea of love is
like La La Land yeah you know and I I
think you know
um as women we've been sold a dream but
you know I think you you took more
responsibility more than the other girls
on those panels I think that's like the
first step right you have to admit and
you have to own your truth so it may not
be like I said there's a lot of harsh
realities with my truth but that's okay
I'm in my truth
whatever is meant to happen it's gonna
happen well thank you for sitting down
with me thank you for having me
um tell them where to find you any
social media you want to plug I do uh
you can find me on Tick Tock because I'm
tic-tac-toeing now
um at the Brittany Renner you can find
me on Instagram at bundle of Brittany
I'm going to be doing more on my YouTube
channel so it's Brittany Renner with two
r's or else Twitter Brittany Renner with
two r's and I am gonna be doing my own
show
um in 2023 so be on the lookout for that
and um yeah I'm excited thank you for
having me thanks for coming
um also I'm look for me in her new book
I
want nothing but good things absolutely
I want it to be just like oh yeah
virtuous amazing as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible